Okay, you've got Android Studio up and
running, awesome work.
Now, you're going to participate in
an important programming tradition.
Making a hello world app.
This is the basically the first step
towards becoming an Android developer.
And at the end of the lesson, you're
going to take this hello world app and
you're going to change it
into the birthday card app.
So, you might be wondering what
exactly is a hello world program.
Well, typically in
programming languages,
one of the easiest things you could do
is print out some words to the screen.
So therefore, usually the first program
that will make it in a programming
language is a program that
will do exactly that.
Print some words out to the screen.
It's kind of like when you're studying a
new human language, how you learn words
like thank you or please or
excuse me where's the bathroom?
A sort of your first building
blocks of that language.
Okay, let's build the hello world app.
A quick note before we get started.
This video was recorded April 6, 2015.
Now, my suggestion to you is that you
don't follow along with the video.
Instead, go ahead and
watch the video through once.
After you're done with that,
we've provided some text instructions
on the instructor notes.
From time to time, Android Studio is
updated, which means that menus or
screens can look a little bit different.
And while the video
might be out of date,
the text instructions will be
updated a lot more regularly.
Okay, so, if you've closed
Android Studio, go ahead and
reopen Android Studio.
You should be starting at this screen.
I'm going to go ahead and
click on this aptly named,
start a new
Android Studio Project button.
All right,
that should take you to this screen,
where we have a couple
of different options.
The first one is the application name.
This is the name that you'll see in
the app bar at the top of the app
as well as the all app
screen of the device.
Preemptively, I'm going to go ahead and
they name this happy birthday.
Okay, right below this
we have company domain.
And if this looks similar to
a web address, you're right.
Normally if you owned a web address,
you type it in here.
Now, at one point in my life
I owned lylaujiwara.com.
So, if I was making an app for
myself, instead of a demo app for
all of you, I will go ahead and
change this to lylafujiwara.com.
Now, you might be wondering why.
Well, if I was planning to
distribute my app on Google Play,
this package name down here is something
that I need to uniquely identify my app.
Meaning, that across all of the people
in the world who are making apps,
this needs to be completely unique.
Now, if we look a little bit
more at the structure of this,
the package name is actually
the company domain reversed.
So, instead of lylafujiwara.com,
we have com.lylafujiwara.
Followed by the application
name with no spaces.
So while there might be a couple of
different app developers that make
a happy birthday app, you're not
going to have a bunch of app developers
that all own lilafujiwara.com and
are making a birthday card app.
And in the way that the Internet is
set up, if I buy lylafujiwara.com,
that means I should have complete
control over what is shown there and
nobody else can buy that domain name.
And if I own it and it's specific to me,
then, that helps ensure that this
package name is completely unique.
So, I know that you only know
about package names right now.
You might not know what a package is.
We'll talk about that
more a little bit later.
But the thing that you just need to
keep in mind right now is that a package
name needs to be unique so
that Google Play and
your phone has a unique way
to identify your application.
Okay, but you're not me and
you don't own this domain.
And since we're all
practicing together and
I want us all to have sort
of the same set up for
this app, I'm going to change
this to android.example.com.
And you should go ahead and
use the same company domain name
because I know that some of you won't
actually own website domains yourself.
Also, it will be back our code.
And if you look below, you should see
that it says com.example.android.
Again, that's the reverse
of Android example com.
And that it says happy
birthday after it.
Okay, so the next thing that you
can change is the project location.
This is where all the files
that have to deal with your app
will be saved on your computer.
Now, usually Android Studio
will create a folder for
your Android Studio projects.
And the default is to just put
your app inside this folder.
And you can see that the name actually
matches the name of the folder
that it will be in.
This is a pretty good default location,
so unless you have any strong reason to
change it,
I'd go ahead to just click next.
Okay, now this is a fun screen.
It let's us pick what phones and
devices that we're going to
actually make our application for.
Now, you're making an app for
a phone and a tablet.
And you're not trying to make an app for
TV wear or glass.
So, we're going to leave
these all unchecked.
The drop down right here shows us the
version of the Android operating system
that our application will support.
We're going to go ahead and scroll up.
You can see that the first public and
widely used release of
Android was called cupcake.
With this release,
Google started a convention where they
would continue to go alphabetically.
But name each operating system
off of desserts or sugary treats.
Cupcake was followed by donut and
eclair.
And this is why you'll see words like
ice cream sandwich, honeycomb, and
KitKat in the dropdown menu.
Now below this dropdown, you'll see
this handy help me choose link.
This graph shows some helpful
percentages of how many people who have
Android phones use the different
operating system versions.
Looking at it,
we can see that most users,
at least of the time of this recording,
are using the deliciously named KitKat.
The percentages,
show the percentages of people in
the world using Google Play who will be
able to use our app if we pick one of
these as our minimum supported version.
So if you pick the newest
version of the operating system,
which is Lollipop,
at least at the time of this recording,
only users with new phones would
be able to download your app.
And that would mean you'd only have
about 0.1% of all of the phone users
actually able to download your app.
So you might be asking,
why not make an app for
all phones by picking the oldest
version of the operating system?
Here's a picture of the first
commercially available Android phone.
The T-mobile G1,
which is also known outside
the United States as the HTC Dream.
It was released in 2008 and
ran Android 1.0.
Obviously a lot has changed since then.
For example, apps like Google Wallet,
which let you pay for groceries with
the wave of your smartphone,
require a Near Field Communication.
A Near Field Communication or NFC, was
actually a type of hardware that didn't
make it into Android phones until 2010.
So if you're making
an app that requires NFC,
there's no reason to even try
supporting older phones like this
that are running older versions
of the Android operating system.
Anyway, for the purposes of your app,
I want you to use API 15
which is ice cream sandwich.
This should work for
about 90% of the phone users out there.
All right, go ahead and click next.
I want to interrupt here for
an important update.
Since filming the original video,
the activity templates have
actually been updated and changed.
So, your screens are going to look
a little bit different than what you're
seeing in the video right now.
If you're using
Android Studio Version 1.4 or newer,
you're going to see
these screens instead.
And instead of selecting blank activity,
what I want you to do is select
the empty activity template.
This will generate the correct files
that will allow you to follow along with
the rest of the course.
On this screen, you're given a bunch of
starting templates you can choose from.
Depending on what you're trying to make.
You're going to go ahead
choose blank activity,
which is already selected,
because it's the sublist one.
And I'm going to click Next.
Finally, this screen gives you
the opportunities to name a couple of
different files that are going to
be automatically generated for
your application.
As you'll soon see, an application is
composed of all the picture files,
sound files, XML files, Java files, and
more that are required to make the app.
Basically, there are a lot of files that
work together to make your application.
We'll talk about this all soon.
For now, take a look at the layout name.
You've been working on XML layout files.
So this is the name of the file we'll
be editing in just a little bit.
I'm actually not going to
change any of these defaults.
So you can go ahead and click finish.
Now, depending on your computer speed,
it might take a moment
to set everything up.
If you look down here,
you'll actually see a little loading
circle as well as a loading bar.
And we can see a loading
circle down here as well,
meaning that it's continuing
to think about things.
So, take a break.
Go ahead, stretch.
And get some tea.
I mean coffee.